[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, everyone.
I'm Nathan.
I'm part of the
Cardboard VR team.
And as many of you know
we created Cardboard
with one simple idea, to
let everyone in the world
get a great VR
experience using nothing
more than the phone
in their pocket
and the world's most
inexpensive HMD.
Now, that sounds simple
and of course executing
that is harder than it sounds.
And the main challenge is that
when you build VR for everyone,
you find out that most
people have everyday phones
and you need to build
apps that work on them.
Well if you look at amongst
our Cardboard users today,
two of the most popular phones
are the brand new Nexus 6P
and the Samsung
Galaxy S4 from 2013.
And of course when you
think about covering
that range of devices in VR, the
number one thing we think about
is simulator sickness, right.
If older phones mean
lower performance,
lower performance
means higher latency,
higher latency makes
users sick and we never
want to make users sick.
There's another, I think,
more fundamental challenge
for those of us building VR
experiences on mobile devices.
And that's that we want
to make experiences
for devices that
run on batteries
and make them just as
compelling as VR experiences
that are meant to run
on devices that connect
to your local power plant.
Covering this performance
and fundamentally energy gap
is a really important part
of making great mobile VR
for everyone.
We've learned a
lot about how to do
this over the last
couple of years at Google
and I'm going to share three
techniques with you today.
The first one has to do
with lens distortion.
So lenses are what make
essentially VR possible.
They're what allow you to
take a screen that's just
a couple of inches
from your eyeballs
and feel like you're looking
out onto an expansive world.
But they have a
downside, and that's
that these lenses
actually warp the picture
that you're looking at.
When you view VR through a lens,
what should be a straight line
becomes curved.
And the way you fix
this is actually you
counter-warp your image, which
most people do in two passes.
You render your image
normally and then
you use post-processing
to counter-warp
it to compensate for the lens.
But of course two
passes is twice as slow
as one pass, especially on
mobile GPUs which are really,
really bandwidth constrained.
So a better solution is to
do your warping actually
in the vertex shader.
Everything that you
can do per pixel
you can actually do per vertex,
as long as your geometry is
reasonably well tessellated.
And for most game
developers out there,
your geometry is already
tessellated enough
for this technique to work.
The second thing I want to talk
to you about a spatial audio.
And one of my favorite
game development quotes
is, music makes you feel,
sound makes it real.
And I think there's
no medium where that's
more true than virtual reality.
So if you want to really create
an efficient sense of presence
in your VR apps and games,
go for broke with the audio.
But when you do, keep
two things in mind.
The first is you want to use
really good spatialization.
Most game developers
are familiar with stereo
panning where you hear
louder sounds from the left
or from the right.
But in VR you want to use
binaural spatialization
so that you can hear sounds
above you and below you,
in front of you and behind you
and really feel like you're
immersed in the soundscape.
The second thing you
want to do is really
think about the
environment within
in which your sound takes place.
Obviously this talk
that I'm giving
would sound very different
if it was in a cave instead
of this big open hall.
So when you're
modeling your sounds,
model not just
the spatialization
but the environmental
rendering and
environmental characteristics
that your game is set in.
Lastly, I want to talk to
you about HD 360 video.
VR video is an incredibly
powerful narrative device.
If you want to quickly
tell a story in VR
or create a sense
of presence, there's
no better way to do that
than using 360 VR video.
The challenge is that VR
video is really demanding.
It needs a very high resolution.
You want to have it
like 3K or 4K on a side.
And it's a really high bit rate.
Good VR starts at
about 2.5 megabytes
per second, which is a lot to
pack into your APK or to stream
from your server.
There's a bigger
problem actually
which is that a lot of
phones can't actually
decode video higher than 1080p.
So even if you
have great content
and you've packed
it into your APK,
some phones won't be
able to handle it.
To solve that
problem we're going
to cheat like crazy in this way.
So the first thing to realize
is that most video is actually
largely static.
In this example video
frame the gorilla is moving
and we're really interested
in his movements,
but the trees in the background
are functionally static.
So we'll start with a single
static frame of our video.
And then we can actually
build video just
of the interesting
parts that move
by stacking the moving section
of the left eye and right
eye on top of each other.
You combine that with
a static alpha mask,
because video on
mobile doesn't actually
support an alpha channel.
And then you can build a little
simple optical compositor
to composite the static
background of the dynamic movie
video pieces, project those
onto a sphere for either eye,
and congratulations, now
you have highly compatible,
highly performing,
10:1 compressed VR
video for smartphones.
If you're interested in learning
more about any of this stuff,
please check out
the Cardboard SDK
online, which has
examples and code
support for all this stuff.
And with that I'll introduce
my colleague, Eiton.
[MUSIC PLAYING]